- I'm trying to
get cozy as shit.
(DRock laughs)
Somebody tweeted
DailyVee and chill.
- [DRock] Really?
- I'm just laughing.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
- [Gary] Little bit of a
curveball this morning.
Was going from Newark to
Chattanooga for our Chattanooga
holiday party but
that was canceled.
So now I'm flying to Atlanta
connecting and then driving for
two hours to Chattanooga.
(tape rewinding)
Should I give away
25 FaceTimes for Christmas?
(DRock laughs)
Yeah.
I mean the amount of people
that are tweeting all I want for
Christmas is a FaceTime
with GaryVee is funny.
("May" by Aire Atlantica)
Make me that Facebook video,
do something smart
with influencers,
do something smart with accounts
that can amplify media accounts
and (censored)
on Facebook. Right?
Get me a startup new thing
and give me PR and
I'm gonna make
the list of PR so you
have to understand.
Yeah, I'm all over the place.
So listen, I'm really
excited to connect.
I'm excited, this is my singular
biggest investments
of my career.
I've heard prior to this call
that you have some level of
context for me which is good
because then I think we'll be
talking kind of
on the same language.
I genuinely believe, I believe
in this space remarkably.
When I started looking under the
hood of what they were building
and what their ambition was
it is 100,000% clear to me by
spending time with all the
executives that I do CMOs, CEOs
that value of, if they
could deliver on this message.
They've got the
product potential, right?
And they've got the thesis
and there's a real
lack of competition.
If they can actually
deliver on this mission
in a world where
I really know that
there's nobody
ahead of them and
I know that (censored) and
(censored) who I have
relationships with are
absolutely gonna make
an acquisition in the space.
It's just a big play.
- [Qunicy] As a quarterback--
- [Gary] Yes?
- [Qunicy] I'm coming out,
you haven't done
the quarterback shit yet.
- [Gary] Yep.
- [Qunicy] You
guys haven't done it.
- [Gary] No, I haven't.
- [Qunicy] Why do I say,
"Alright, I trust
GaryVee to take my
career and to the next level?"
- 'Cause my seven-year-old
daughter can on Google and tell
you which camp, which trainer,
which right thing you need to do
on a football level and because
it's your fucking heart and your
arm and your brain and all the
other stuff I have to execute
for you and there's
been plenty of guys,
plenty of guys who supposed
to go in the first round.
I follow football hard.
I know the Jets practice
squad so this is my life.
You know, I just know
the stories. You know?
I know the stories and so
I think the reason a quarterback
comes with us, look does a
number one or number two pick in
the NFL draft next year, some
the guys are projected are they
gonna come with us?
I am not, as
egotistical as I feel right now,
I'm not naive and I recognize
that some of the biggest
agencies in world are
gonna have the tactics.
They probably got
'em locked up already.
So, I'm a big boy.
I think that to be very frank
and you haven't been in a
meeting with me
like this yet Quinc,
I don't want to sell them on me.
I really don't.
I'm empathetic.
- [Quincy] Mhmmm.
- You've been
courted since you were 13.
Right, you, your parents have
been hoping you'll never get
hurt and
everything's gonna be okay
and now you're finally here.
You made it through and
what are you gonna take this
crazy high risk on a startup?
But I took risks on startups.
I bet my hundreds and hundreds
of thousands dollars that's all
I had in my bank on Facebook.
- [Quincy] Mhmmm.
- [Gary] It worked and so the
same reason that I was able to
make tens of millions of dollars
on that I think that every kid
that signs with us is going
to disproportionally get our
attention, our execution and
what's gonna end up happening is
a lot of these kids aren't gonna
be the ones that sign with us
'cause they're not smart
enough to and you know what,
they actually may
be smart enough to,
their handlers aren't.
Their uncle,
you know, their dad,
their mom so I'm not even
worried about getting a top-five
quarterback in this, this
draft it's not happening.
It's not really
happening overall.
May, little bit, one guy.
Next year's draft, I don't
expect to happen but in what is
that '17, '18, in 2019 draft we
will have the number one pick
overall if it's a
quarterback and we'll have 'em.
Because by then it will be clear
as day that VaynerSports has
fundamentally changed the game
in a way because we're gonna
have 38 guys who
are gonna be like,
"Okay, this is different shit."
- [Quincy] Mhmmm.
- And I've got, I'm friends with
NFL stars who are pinging me,
I just, I'm staying
away from everything.
I don't know the rules.
You gotta wait to the blackout,
I'm like so
I'm just staying passive.
I'm staying in the weeds a
little bit like a cobra.
I know nobody's
paying attention.
I don't think any of the big
boys are paying attention to me.
- [Quincy] They are.
- Well I'm hoping they're not.
This interview might
fuck me up a little bit.
But I'm planning on jumping out
of the fucking grass and doing
my thing and so you know,
it's a foregone conclusion.
I'm excited about it but these
kids are making their entire
life's decision and then you
learn bullshit like wait a
minute so you're telling me that
if you're actually in the bowl
series and you're going out and
you haven't really talked to any
agents behind the scenes or
a little bit or kinda sorta,
what you got four weeks to make
the biggest decision of your
life of who you're going into
business with before the...
Shotgun weddings.
- [Quincy] Mhmmm.
- There's a lot of broken
shit and I plan on changing it.
Proud of you man.
Really am.
- [Quincy] Thank you.
It was awesome.
So what are you
guys up to now? Chillin'?
- No, I've got to go to this
holiday party and then the road.
- [Quincy] Gotcha.
- Alright, ready?
You know where we're going?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- [Quincy] I appreciate it.
Mad busy.
- [Gary] I'm glad
you made the schlep.
It's the grind, I love it.
No, I trust your opinion
that he's gonna be a player.
But, I know for a fact he
might go seventh round.
- [Quincy] He knows, definitely.
- [Gary] He may not get drafted.
Could happen.
It depends on like, but
that's why we're like,
okay if we do
this, we're doing it.
("Arizona" by Common Souls)
- My name is Glen Harry.
- Jordan Horton.
- I'm Desirae.
- I'm Lizzy.
- Jesse Hutchinson here,
account director at the
Chattanooga office.
- I'm Jacob.
- Molly.
- Kate.
- Angela.
- Chris Logsdon, I am the
creative director down here at
the VaynerMedia
Chattanooga office.
- [Gary] A lot of you know me or
know a lot about me and some of
you may know, actually,
not a lot of you know this.
That I basically married my wife
somewhere within the first four
minutes of our first date and
called her after our date as she
was going upstairs to her
apartment and started with the
opening line of
"Can you believe this is it?"
So I, also, some
of you know this,
Mickey I think you
were in the room.
I walked into a meeting that
I think we were org'ing some
department and told
AJ, oh yeah, I bought,
I kinda acqui-hired
an entire agency.
We now have an LA office.
Basically where I'm going with
this and I'll cut it short is
I've made a lot of big
decisions in my life very,
very, very quickly and
I did that with this town.
- Favorite part of 2016
was just being
down in Chattanooga
building this team up and
just the camaraderie
that's down here.
Winning new
business is always fun,
especially when
it's a small office.
- If I had to think about my top
memory of 2016 I'd say it's kind
of a collection of watching
our team members grow,
kick ass at work, really kind
of roll through it together.
And if I had to think of
anything that I'm really,
really excited for in
2017 it's crushing it again,
growing this team, getting some
more business and even doing it
bigger and better.
- [Gary] As I sat there and
watched this scene tonight was,
this was another
one of my very, very,
very good
intuitive quick decisions.
To watch what this
unit has become,
to watch how this unit has
absorbed what I thought was a
really fun Vayner birthday
thing that we all hung out.
The only time I've been to a
sporting event where I did not
watch one second of the event
and the newcomers that have
joined the team along
the way since then,
I'm very, very proud of
what's going on here.
And all you also know
that I do not micromanage.
I put people in charge,
I watch you,
I watch you guys grow.
There's so many people
here that are pieces of this.
It's not just a Mickey story.
It's a collective
story and I'm very,
very proud of all
of you and I'm very,
very, very thankful, too.
I wish all of you in your life
and you feel it a little bit
when you become parents and you
feel when you become managers
and you feel it when
you've mentored somebody
but you know when you
start getting to some level of
scale of having people follow
your vision and you created
infrastructure and a company of
this size, it's my
biggest fear was always
the thing that
I always told you
I was never scared of
because I'm really not
but it's a fake fear but
I actually wouldn't
call it a fear.
It's the thing that is always
on my mind which is at scale how
far away do we get from the soul
and the heart that AJ and I set
out to do with this company.
There is, there's nothing
closer to the heart of what this
organization is than
this office right here and
I thank you very much for that.
I think next year is
gonna be a remarkable year.
You'll hear this tomorrow
from me but I've a very,
very distinct vision of what
needs to be a stunning portion
of the amount of work we do here
and I think it's
gonna excite all of you.
I think we'll do some great work
here and Mickey and I've been
working very hard setting that
up mentally and with some of the
pieces and
decision moving forward,
I think it's gonna be extremely
bright for this amazing office.
I'm very, very honored to
be part of the Chattanooga
community and what's happening
in this amazing state and
I'm just very,
very happy tonight.
And so, thank you.
(group applause)
I have a 6 A.M.
workout in New York City
(group laughter)
so I'll be leaving shortly
but I hope you guys
have a wonderful holiday.
Take advantage of it.
Rest, I appreciate the hustle.
My big thing is I have to
workout at 6 A.M., you know?
("Arizona" by Common Souls)
Just vlogging your Uber driving.
I'm traveling as if like...
Good meeting.
Love ya, brother.
Take care of
yourself, thank you.
That we're not in control
creates vulnerability for us.
Obviously you should control,
they can do their measurement
but it's on their terms,
their measurement.
So I told him my skin in
the game was not
running it profitably.
Deploying my team, us,--
- [Woman] Okay.
- my content team 'cause I'm gonna
micromanage it so our
skin in the game is that.
- [Woman] Alright.
- And open to anything they come
up with that I would approve.
- [Woman] Got it. Okay.
- [Gary] Let's go.
- [Woman 2] So can
I carry anything for you?
Long day.
Headed back to
New York City from Chattanooga.
6 A.M. workout, land in
Jersey at midnight, 12:30.
It's a grinder.
DRock, you're so fancy.
You're always
flying private, DRock.
Bougy as shit, bougue.
Bouge-Rock.
- [DRock] You look
really cozy there, Gary.
- I'm trying to
get cozy as shit.
- [DRock] Netflix and chill?
- Somebody tweeted
today, "DailyVee and chill."
- [DRock] Really?
- I was laughing.
("Arizona" by Common Souls)